Little Ricky can we bring out little
Ricky you guys want to do a little mini
interview with Ricky yeah yeah we'd love
to yeah sure has Ricky ever has Ricky
ever done an interview before this is
his first interview he's ever done so
this is an exclusive this is a world
exclusive and I wanted to bring him here
because although his mixtape was leaked
out Ricky has been working on a lot of
music I've been helping executive
produce some of it and uh Ricky
Ricky what did you put in this there's
no lactose in that is there oh dude it's
all milk that's whole milk that's that's
heavy whipping cream yeah that's heavy
cream and just a little bit of coffee
you didn't really have any of it I know
why is that cuz I knew you were a sipper
I knew you like to sip other people's
drinks it was a trap the whole time you
going to have the rest of that do you
want it I would love it really oh bro I
get pumped up I'm sober so I have to do
something so you're all you're like a
caffeine guy strung out no I'm not but I
would like to try it
would you mind let us in hand here I you
got it you guys got
it it's going well it's close I can
almost touch
it there you go there it
is ass no it's good that's bad and what
about
you you guys are there the right
teamwork
Ricky can we bring in Little Ricky
please holy [__] [__] there he is
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the show
Little Ricky Make Some Noise holy
[__] stop Ricky stop Ricky stop get the
[__]
away hey hey hey hey knock it
off
you [__] dick sit down sit the [__]
down can I swear yeah you can C sit the
[__] down right
now this guy is huge yeah yeah he's
going to be a big star so uh Lil Ricky
Ricky you got such a crazy look man what
planet are you from he's actually from
zeter bauli it's a zr3 That's The Hyphen
but it's a binary I just I was hoping
Ricky could tell it though sorry I got
to it's all good it's all good and he's
come a very long way as well yeah um how
you yeah how' you guys meet uh actually
interestingly enough we grew up together
he used to visit my house growing up
what it's all good I got it what no I'm
just Oh I thought you were asking me no
no no we want to talk to Ricky I mean we
just an exclusive yeah yeah anything um
open book Ricky we yeah he's a complete
is this an open book situation he's a
complete open book whatever you guys
want want to add nothing's off the table
Yeah okay as deep as we want as deep huh
okay I I got a spicy one then all right
Ricky why won't Oliver let you release
your D all right that's enough dude yeah
yeah really these bro these are not the
right questions stop Rick Ricky Ricky
what's your favorite podcast these are
not the right questions these are not
the questions we agreed on first of all
you said this was going to be a puff
piece we never said that we never said
that at all yes you did I think you
thought it was going to be a puff piece
you brought you said favorite colors
favorite food we're not doing all this
[__] Ricky stop grabbing [__] yeah you
can have that actually Ricky that's a
gift for you Ricky yeah Ricky we hope
you that album comes out soon man we
hope we can get it got leaked for your
information and it had nothing to do
with it what is your favorite food it
doesn't matter Ricky get the [__] out of
here no just
go no don't [__] touch
anything well Ricky we lik having you
here man yeah Ricky stop knocking [__]
over you [__] dick yeah you know what
get out of here
oh oh oh stop Ricky
chill what hey hey hey there's no need
for that [__] dick stop stop
Ricky what are you doing I'm so sorry
you guys he's not normally like this
that's kind of an [__] man must be
pretty hard to be on your label eh yeah
yeah you winding up his feelings I mean
he doesn't seem I'm the easiest dude to
work
with there nothing hard about being on
alien Boy Records you seem like
pretty who who is that who the heck is
this wait I have no idea who's here
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa
[Laughter]
whoa what the hell are you guys doing
here you guys sit down sit down who are
these
guys down here you're good here come
over
here
so this is the new EDM group I've signed
it's super computer and there's nothing
hard about being on alien Boy Records
everybody knows Oliver tree is a fun
easygoing guy to work with and these
two they know better than anyone how
much fun it is to be on alien Boy
Records so have they been ever been
interviewed before no this is the
world's first and it's a very big deal
because they've never been interviewed
before
I just asked that question wow so when
did you guys sign with they signed last
week oh cool well uh so what was it like
working with Oliver on the song essence
you guys together we had so much fun so
we were in Brazil in this glass house it
was like right up in the jungle and we
had this rooms you could just see the
full jungle and every day we were
swimming you talk do they get to talk
yeah they do I'm just answering the
question oh well it was for them if you
don't mind I'd love to answer your
question question with another question
have you ever been to Rio De Janeiro no
Brazil no never bro that is the greatest
place in the world swimming the jungles
the food the papayas yeah you guys would
love it cool who's under the mask who's
under the mask all right you guys these
are not the questions I
wrote what I mean this is not the
[__] questions we agreed on we didn't
agree on any questions yes we did well
before this [__] thing pod man it's a
free flowing thing no don't do this
[__] no this is [__] broing out
[__] tactics this is classic
journalist 101 [__] no this is your
[__] no this is [__] [__] on
your behalf no you bring your artists in
here and they they pop up and and you
know we we promote your big live show
with little kids kissing each other and
stuff and now we're here with your
artists and we want to interview them
and now you're being all weird about I'm
not being weird about who's under the
mask I'm not doing this [__] [__]
dude oh what you about to walk off we're
going to [__] walk right now oh yeah
yeah we'll [__] go okay buddy let's
see you go first you've been talking a
big game I'm [__] done with this [__]
I've given you everything I put on the
greatest [__] podcast of all time is
how you're going to repay me no no you
know what they want their identity
completely mysterious I'm going to
respect that if you guys can't we're
walking then go then we will you guys
ready let's
go follow me let's go let's [__] go
wait a minute you always no you know
Oliver get back here get back I'm not
getting back Oliver get back
here nice to meet you guys we're done
dud Oliver you know what you always get
back here you always do this [__]
come back here we're not done get you go
on you have some stupid beat you put
your stupid [__] poster up it's not
stupid come over
here we're ending this
amicably now stand right
here we're ending this on a positive
note thank you for coming thanks for
coming dude we are not ending on a
negative note we're having a good time
right mhm we had a great time we had
okay time it was a great interview right
right thank you for coming did you have
fun right no I didn't had fun no I
didn't have fun I wanted to
do he had a lot of [__] fun he had a
lot of fun I'm not doing this anymore
this isn't
Fun oh wait you think this will work
should we give it yeah wait oh yeah hit
it
oops